en france réquisitoire sévère et
inattendue de l'avocat général au procès
vilma jacques caunes a requis une peine
minimum de dix ans pour le meurtre de
bernard laroche dominique verdeilhan
gilles dobler
décompose et christine villemin quitte
le palais de justice il y à quelques
minutes à peine elle s'effondrait dans
les bras de son époux jean marie
ensemble ils ont longuement sangloter en
entendant ce qu'il n'attendait pas au
moins dix ans de prison requis les mots
de l'avocat général sont implacables
jean marie villemin un homme dangereux
qui a agi avec une des solutions froide
et méthodique jean marie villemin a
décidé de condamner à mort bernard
laroche on n'a pas le droit de se faire
justice soi même légitime défense oui
légitime assassinat non l'avocat général
a une profonde conviction l'innocence de
christine villemin dans le meurtre de
grégory mais rien de définitif n'a été
établi concernant l'innocence ou la
culpabilité de bernard laroche certes
jean marie villemin était un homme
poussé à bout par un sentiment
d'injustice mais son geste n'a pas
apaisé sa fureur il a compromis
définitivement toute possibilité
d'identifier le corbeau la défense parle
d'acquittement la partie civile de peine
de principe l'avocat général de prison
depuis le 3 novembre nous avions l'image
d'un père et pleurer ce matin l'avocat
général nous a présenté un justicier
dangereux sans remords neuf ans après
les faits le parquet émet l'hypothèse
d'une troisième piste neuf ans après les
faits on est revenu à la case départ 29
audience durant lesquelles on a instruit
les procès de christine villemin et de
bernard laroche et ce matin un retour en
arrière brutale jean marie villemin est
le seul coupable connu de ce dossier et
seule certitude à dijon c'est bien le
père de grégory qu'on juge